today is an interesting trip today is an
intra streets for [ __ ] Nick this is
what he did he was [ __ ] up on camera
and now his little [ __ ] Chinglish
[ __ ] transferred over to me from
Thailand feel free to message me DM me
with any sort of advice that you're
looking for I will be more than welcome
for that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
saying yeah right you know - good job
back thank you I appreciate that look
from today was an interesting day today
was an interesting day we are outside of
fight academy Pasadena it's where I go
train and I just got done and so I'm
gonna go into a little ticket Aki I show
you guys what I've been up to for the
past three four months as I lost my 42
to 45 pounds depending on whether I take
a poop in the morning or not you guys
never poop sometimes it's mirrors all
over the place how did I say that as you
can see we are in a fight gym if you
guys have been following me on instagram
you guys already know I have been
training to join the UFC I'm finally
Anderson Silva tomorrow I'm kidding
Anderson Silva you are my hero when you
broke your shin and Chris Weidman did it
with that me check it was like watching
Michael Jordan go for a layup and
smashing his teeth on the rim I cried
but I wanted to show you guys this this
this part of my life just because a lot
of you have been curious about what's
been keeping me motivated to lose weight
now when I first started losing weight
as you guys saw in a previous video it I
just walked
I woke up every day I got my fat ass out
of bed inspired by David Coggins and I
just walked three to four miles well
after a while you start to plateau and
it kind of needed to find a new goal for
myself
you guys saw me lose about 42 pounds in
the last four to five months it didn't
it wasn't overnight
it wasn't like these like Instagram
Fitness pages where you see like yo in
30 days I'm gonna get a six-pack and a
huge [ __ ] dig well it's hard it takes
time it takes effort and above all else
if you have a habit of doing things that
make you comfortable this comfort is
gonna bother you a lot
and so that's just something that you
have to work past it like I always say
success is always on the other side of
this Comfort so that's why I come here
to Train and I'm here to give you guys a
little sample of what I'll be doing so
today we're gonna be training with Davis
we're gonna start off a little bit of
mitts we're gonna kind of work on his
mechanics and how he's punching because
he always drops his hands he was sorry
okay gotcha okay so talk louder all
right today we're working with David we
working some mitts we're gonna be making
sure his mechanics or sound because he
drops his hands a lot he keeps his chin
white up so we're gonna focus on a
couple slow isolation drills where we
could hone in and make sure he doesn't
do that anymore then we're gonna do some
we're gonna do some light sparring
drills where he doesn't do anything like
that that's pretty much what we're gonna
be doing today
[Music]
hook
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay my hands hurt you [ __ ] okay so now
we're just gonna be adding a little more
weapons into the drill now so we just
start off with hands then we slowly
added kicks so I'm gonna be throwing the
kicks a little faster rate and I want to
see his reaction time and how well he
kid check counter and attack right after
and as you guys can see from the
training compared to the first time I
was getting missed the second time like
conditioning has a lot to do with it and
also like a certain mentality when I
figured out because that was very weak
mentality just cuz I know I hired him
and I could leave whatever I want yeah
everybody thinks is easy everybody
thinks oh my god the only in there for
three minutes how long can that be
you've been but [ __ ] for three minutes
it's an eternity how do you get
everything that you learn every mechanic
every like technical ability whatever
and do that still while you're exhausted
and as you can see towards the end of
that cliff hands drop when I was
throwing the jab or the cross my chin
was going up feet was getting flat and
that's the hard part you know a lot of
you keyboard warriors out there saying
like oh my god their feet are flat well
have you ever been in a ring for [ __ ]
five rounds shut the [ __ ] up eat your
cereal jack off to your anime porn and
sit the [ __ ] down
you know there's nothing a pretty good
Saturday can I join ya start picking the
speed a little faster oh we're like kind
of like almost at a smart pace you go
[Music]
[Music]
so these these are the drills that's
gonna replicate a sparring type
situation he knows what I'm throwing at
him so we're relatively safe if he
misses the block that's kinda on him if
I miss a block it's same on me right
because we're understand understanding
where he knows what's coming
I know what's coming he's not sweaty you
don't have sweat glands
nice dress wet boy it's like right under
my tits we're gonna piss a little wet
right here where there's no sweat it's
not coming out yet oh I win I win winds
velocity so I kind of wanted to leave
this open to you guys and ask you guys
if you want to come in and train with me
not trained in the sense of like learn
how to fly per se just because I know
that a lot of people when it comes to
fitness or just martial arts in general
people tend to be a bit apprehensive
thinking that you have to come in here
and get your ass knocked out and that's
that's not really what it's about you
guys know I've been on this like funny
fat thick rind and I'm thinking about
towards the end of August doing an event
where you guys can come out and have fun
with me talk about your personal life
experiences your your struggles with
weight loss weight gain
you know self-image and I really want to
help people out there who's going
through the similar stuff that I went
through and I'm gonna have Nick come
along with me and he's gonna help give
you guys a session if you guys want to
do that come out meet talk have a
conversation share your story leave it
in the comments below let me know if you
guys want to do that and I'll set it up
if you guys want to find Nick you can
check them out you could actually see
them on my Instagram I always plug them
all the
when I train but you'll find them at
Nick the ear on Instagram you can see
him at fight academy Pasadena come
through come train with them and if not
I'll see you guys at the event if you
want me to do it
because I'm really excited to meet you
guys peace out you kicked me the dick
earlier by the way that's how you do it
that's how your [ __ ] slog off that's
how you sign off that's right right he
split the beans right in the middle they
went this way yeah David sorry see that
you always need an Asian coach because
no matter how good you're doing they're
gonna tell you're a piece of [ __ ] that's
Asian parenting 101 that's how I got to
be mentally damaged as I am today
there you go cheap shot
[Music]
you throw an extra punch Oh son of a
[ __ ] that's right dude what the [ __ ]
I'm exhausted
you're like I can't even keep my hands
up right now dude